here at the edge of the universe I look
into the abyss at man that a new
spacesuit
well we're back I'm back most
importantly and this time we've got all
of your favorite Justice League
superheroes and we're battling Brainiac
and Joker all those other guys I can't
stand Lego Batman - we kind of got to
see some of your favorite DC superheroes
join forces in Gotham to try and upset
Lex Luthor and Joker and now you get to
see your favorite heroes and villains
get together again but this time on a
much larger scale we leave Gotham and we
even leave the boundaries of Earth whoa
I think Superman finds fighting crime
and intergalactic territory not that big
of a deal the man has superpowers he can
fly it's got super hair tell you what
makes a great hero toys the money helps
I'm going to take him down Oh
I am back any chance to play the Joker
is is a wonderful experience Joker's
like a 4th of July fireworks display
he's there you can see everything that's
going on
Lex kind of smoldering Lex keeps a lot
of it inside so in that sense Lex and
Joker are a really great team it's
interesting because Lego Batman is so
different than just the normal Batman
franchise it still has the same
characters at the core but they're kind
of exaggerated and maybe the things that
make them quirky are brought out more
any defining characteristics that you
know about how you know he kind of
wisecracks all of that all of that gets
turned on yeah we kind of teased fans in
the last game that there was the broader
DC universes part of Lego Batman and we
introduced some of the Justice League
characters for the first time into the
universe and we really wanted to take
that to the next level so we have a huge
cast of DC characters in this game and a
huge cast of voiceover actors to bring
them to life such as Fred Tavish or
Chris Smith Josh Keaton Marc warden
Travis Willingham Laura Bailey Charley
slaughter Troy Baker Dee Bradley Baker
clancy brown roger craig smith and adam
west you know some of the most
despicable individuals I've ever had the
pleasure of working with these guys are
highly accomplished and they're great
improvisers and so we'll just spark
ideas off each other and it becomes
really collaborative that way each one
of the voice performers that you have in
this they are top tier voice actors it
really is a full performance that you're
getting from this it's not just fun it's
interesting and it's as good a voice
performances you're going to get I've
always felt that I've been very
fortunate how many actors get a chance
to create an iconic character that goes
on and on for pete's sake and for me to
have been
this is rewarding it's challenging and
it's fun Lego is all about being fun and
what Lego does especially with these
franchise is you get a chance to look at
something that's very familiar something
that you know inside and out and look at
it in a completely different way and
have fun with it